[Music]
hi everyone Welcome to Cloud next 2022
and our session on solutions for
protecting your data and meeting
compliance using encryption
my name is Olson Lee I'm a group product
manager within the cloud Security Group
working specifically on on key
management and encryption along with me
I have sulkates
hi everybody thanks a little song for
the introduction I'm Solomon Cates
principal technologist for cloud and
cyber security at Talus I spent a lot of
my time working in Cloud security
architectures which I'm really excited
to share with you today back to you
thanks all so today we're going to talk
primarily about two different topics so
first I'll go over some best practices
for a key management in gcp so a lot of
our customers use our Key Management
Solutions to actually protect their data
at rest and so often they have a lot of
questions about things and hopefully
I'll be able to answer some of the more
common ones and then I'll turn over to
Saul who will then actually talk a
little bit about the the data
sovereignty and some of the solutions
that we have between Google and Talus
so first let's talk a little bit about
Key Management best practices
and I'm going to talk through three
questions and these three questions are
once where I get a lot of questions
around and I'd like to help people
understand some of the solutions and
hopefully by the end of this you'll have
learned at least one thing new
the first question is really is around
how do I determine which resources are
protected by my keys
so if you're a gcp user you're often
using keys to protect your data and
specific keys that you control whether
it's something that you you do directly
through encryption or most commonly
through using our customer manager
encryption keys
and so if you're using your customer
Azure encryption Keys you'd probably
have a lot of keys and determine which
keys are used to protect which data may
be a little bit challenging
to help solve this problem we're
providing a couple of Solutions in the
near future and so the first one is
called the key inventory dashboard
and if you use gcp today you know that
when you want to list out all the keys
that you have in a project then you
normally have to click through every
single key ring and then numerate them
all individually well not anymore you'll
be able to use accumulatory dashboard
where you'll be able to actually have a
different different tab that'll list out
all the keys in the flat panel as you
can see on the on the example or on the
screen
the next thing is is that when you go
through this you can actually click on
individual keys and then you can
actually do something called usage
tracking so that uses tracking tab will
actually tell you which CMAC resources
are protected by your key really cool
right
the second question I want to go over is
can I use cloud HSN for TLS offloading
it's not just Cloud HSM but it's also
any other Key Management Service that we
provide so it can be our HSM Keys it can
be our software Keys it can even be an
external key but the HSM is one that
people most often refer to happily I
like to say that you can do this and the
reason you can do this is through our
Cloud KMS pcsys 11 Library you can use
that in conjunction with openssl and
then together with the patch or nginx
you can actually set up an environment
where you terminate the TLs within it
it's actually very very simple to do and
all you need to do is follow the
instructions in the links that are
pasted Below on the slide and with this
you can actually fully use our Key
Management Services in the cloud or an
external key manager to actually protect
the the private starting key the last
question that I want to address is how
do I decide what type of key I should
use
now in gcp we've gone through a lot of
lengths to provide you with a wealth of
different Key Management Solutions to
help you through different types of
scenarios
but sometimes the having a lot of
choices can actually be more confusing
and to understand how to better use this
I'd like to explain a little bit about
the layered approach in terms of how to
how to manage your data
so first of all you should have an
understanding around what your
sensitivity of your data is and so if
it's not as sensitive or moderately
sensitive then you can probably use the
default encryption that we provide and
to remind everyone Google cloud makes
sure that every single piece of data
that you put into into our cloud is
encrypted at Rest by default or if you
need to control the keys then you can
use our customer managed encryption keys
with a cloud KMS software key
now if the data is a little bit more
sensitive than that maybe it faces more
regulatory hurdles and challenges then
you can use cmec with our Cloud HSM key
and then you'll be able to protect all
your data with the hardware key that's
fips 140-2 level 3 certified and that
service that's completely managed by
Google
and then finally if you have very high
sensitive data and this is since this is
data that you probably wouldn't normally
put into the cloud or not traditionally
and I'm talking about things like you
know your highly regular data Maybe
credit card numbers Phi things like this
then you can use cloud H I mean sorry
CMAC with our cloud ekm or external key
manager and by doing this you can
actually keep your data inside the cloud
and use the power of the cloud with keys
are outside
and to talk a little bit more about this
I'm going to turn over to Saul who's
going to talk a little bit more about
cmec and ekm along with data sovereignty
so
thanks Wilson
data sovereignty has become a very
interesting conversation over the last
handful of years Taos has been one of
the leaders in creating Sovereign
architectures and implementations for
some time now but with the Advent of the
cloud and working with organizations
like Google we're starting to see a very
rapid adoption based upon requirements
and regulation when we're looking at
workloads that we're running in the
cloud again like else I mentioned
earlier how you use your keys what kind
of keys you're using where are you
storing them what features are you using
to protect them is it a complicated
conversation for some organizations
we typically get involved at talus in
the medium risk high risk and very high
risk architectures
beginning with the you know externally
managed bring your own key which we'll
talk about here in a following slide it
really sets the stage for Key Management
of customer managed encryption Keys
using external technology and tools that
help to help simplify and minimize the
amount of overhead to keep your data
safe and secure all meeting requirements
external Key Management where you're
actually wanting to hold your keys
externally really dives into things like
gcps Cloud ekm which we'll talk here
again shortly in another slide and then
for those workloads that are very very
sensitive and the organization or the
entity needs to protect the data control
the applications and the entire Suite of
data security we also see bring your own
encryption but today we're going to
focus on bringing on key and hold your
own key
and with that we quite often get asked
how do I use Keys externally what are my
options what are the requirements that I
have to bring in and what kind of
Technologies do I need to support this
and so with that there's really two
paths that we see quite often one is
bring your own key where you as an
entity an organization are importing and
leveraging keys that you are managing
external from the cloud
and this really has a full life cycle
that we'll talk about in the subsequent
slide and this really helps for people
that organizations actually want to have
a key rotation and compliance reporting
that is managed by them hold your own
key is where using Technologies like
taluses cckm Cypher trust Cloud key
manager you can actually host Keys
external from the cloud and leverage
them to protect things like the customer
managed encryption key Within gcp
so with that bring your own key
architecture that we cut off and see is
is not only in protecting the keys
externally that you're creating but
importing them and syncing them and
leveraging them through an entire life
cycle from birth to destruction
including monitoring and rotation this
really helps organizations have full
control over the keys life cycle in the
cloud but also keep their keys on
premise inside of boundaries and borders
that they control
this is a pretty popular architecture
and what what supports this from Telus
is the ciphertress cloud key manager so
not only using cckam for cloud key
management for bring your own key you
can also leverage it for what we call
hold your own key which we support the
Google Cloud ekm functionality this
allows you to create manage and store
your keys outside of Google cloud while
making sure your keys stay within hsm's
on-premise or key managers that you
manage within your jurisdiction this
really allows for data sovereignty where
the keys are kept off Cloud but the data
is stored in Cloud
when we talk to organizations around
things like gdpr and trems too this
becomes a very strong Focus point for us
and our customers and we don't just stop
there Talus and Google have been working
for some time on many other solutions
that integrate our products and
expertise to protect your data in many
other architectures from Google
workspace and the client-side encryption
features you also can manage those
inside your Cypher trust Cloud key
manager to the slew of different use
cases within gcp from bring your own key
hold your own key including ubiquitous
data encryption as well this allows the
organization to use their existing
implementation and Investments for
protecting their keys off Cloud to
actually protect their data on cloud
and we love working together to become
better together we've been for some time
actually introducing more and more
features and functionality for securing
your data wherever it might be and
making sure that you can still leverage
your investments in your hsms and your
key managers that you keep on your
premises but also support more and more
trust and attestation of things running
in the cloud powered by Google and
trusted and secured by Talus we also
highly recommend that you do use cloud
ekm to not only create a seamless
integration of off-cloud Key Management
with on-cloud key usage but really drive
that security and sovereignty of the
data itself to meet your government
requirements or regulatory requirements
beautiful thing is all of these Key
Management capabilities whether they be
bring your own key or hold your own key
or other Integrations from a key
management perspective the same tasks
and be used for the same Keys
particularly with cmec keys
and so with that I want to thank you all
for the time I appreciate it Hillsong
thanks so much Saul and on behalf of
Saul and myself I'd like to thank you
very much for joining our session and we
hope to see you again soon
[Music]